your special uh plan is burning you tell
this story that i i find hard to believe
that it's true it's about
at your hebrew school
and you tell this story and it's a
jaw-dropping story but you maintain this
is absolutely 100 true
100 true you got to tell okay when i
went to so i grew up
on long island nobody grows up in long
island for some reason um
on the island
and uh yes and um
i'm 32 so if this place is a context for
you when i went to hebrew school in the
early 2000s the year 2000 i'm a fan um
uh
we did this thing where like they really
make you as a jewish kid like learn
about the holocaust
they're obsessed which i'm like i get it
okay um
but we we watched really like scary
footage we like learned the details very
young and then we got into this
situation with our in my hebrew school
where we did um
like a reenactment of the holocaust what
and i mean i think it's really good that
they are teaching you about it and
showing you food that's important but
what do you mean reenactment like
there's like civil war reenactments and
this was holocaust reenactments
we were like seriously we were like
trying to escape and we were going
through the truly they turned the
holocaust into an escape room yep
as i say in my special we larped the
holocaust in my hebrew school um we did
holocaust play uh at my hebrew school
it's absolutely insane and and the idea
was to to like oh so you really are
going to experience what it's like to be
some place and you can't leave i'm like
in the hallways of shul no i'm not gonna
actually actually experience this at all
or have any context of what it was like
they like turned the lights out in the
hallways and they had like the older
kids were like these stopping points it
was crazy and so
at the end we there's a pogrom which is
a raid they truly did this and we're
like
we're like screaming we don't know
what's going on and my my friend annie
who's now a lawyer a very
detail-oriented litigious person escaped
the hebrew school and she's outside
waiting in the cold and she thinks
horrors are happening inside
because she just hears screaming and
stuff she just she here screaming and
then we quiet down we're like where's
annie
and annie was like saving herself yeah
so that's insane that's like if they
were teaching me about the irish potato
famine they said no potatoes are food
for you yeah
for two years
you'll eat grass and then you'll
appreciate irish history no
that's a horrible experience so i mean
first of all did you tell your parents
that's the kind of thing where you
immediately go and tell your parents
yeah i don't know my parents weren't the
type to like call the teachers and
complain they were just like
i was like
yeah yeah yeah i was like all right yeah
yeah but i got material out of it so you
know
it was worth it
do they still at this hebrew school do
they still do they still do it i don't
know i don't think they're going to do
it because this is going to get out it's
going to get out
that you told this and they're going to
stop doing it because you can't do that
it's wrong it's wrong and um annie's mom
actually called uh thank god for annie
so annie's mom called and yelled at them
and she texted me her mom donna friedman
texted me uh after watching a special
and she was like i hope miss topak
watched this
this is the best way to air your
grievances is on a late-night talk show
this is how we solve problems here it
was a good synagogue otherwise but what
a bad judgment yeah yeah
i know we'll recreate the yeah uh oh
your uh your stand-up tour is in march
is that when it begins that's right i'm
doing uh i'm going in nine cities in
march and doing stand-up and what do you
wanna do something special after the
shows is that right right so um uh it's
2020. it's a big election year a big
year for voting so every city i go to
for stand-up i'm going to stay an extra
night and throw a voter empowerment
dance party with my political
organization generator
yeah
people have to vote in 2020.
anything anybody can do to get people to
vote whatever your opinions are you've
got to vote this generator collective my
political organization i co-founded with
my friend glennis mahar irish hey
um irish
yeah he's not irish i don't care because
there's
because there's too many of us frankly
you go to the uh no one's yeah whatever
the generator is very much born out of
us trying to understand the system
ourselves so we've learned recently
through our own organization that voting
is important this year as well as the
census right i can't tell you all the
reasons why but i know it's important